[Music]
[Music]
they announced their arrival with a
blast of a horn it's always a sight to
behold when the huge cruise ships make
their way into Kiel it bursts a popular
port for luxury liners which can lay
anchor in the middle of town thanks to
the unusually deep water
[Music]
three large cruise ship terminals ensure
maximum efficiency at peak times the
port processes up to ten thousand
passengers they appreciate the short
journey from the port into town keyless
used to welcoming international visitors
[Music]
every year the ship's ferry some three
hundred and seventy thousand passengers
in and out of the northern German city
it's just a five-minute walk from the
cruise ship terminal to the town center
keel is the university town and its
atmosphere is relaxed northern Germans
are a pretty laid-back lot the sea is an
integral part of life in this part of
Germany yes okay
[Music]
locals are proud of their seafaring
traditions trade with Scandinavia and
the Baltic region was thriving as early
as the 13th century keel is also a
traditional home of the German Navy and
these days the town has its cruise ships
[Music]
the city was badly damaged in the Second
World War
Danish Casa is one of the only streets
to have survived intact
this 17th century manor house is now
home to the Kiel City Museum which
focuses on the city's maritime history
rulers from around Europe found keels
location on the sea highly desirable at
one point the city actually belonged to
the king of Denmark the town hall tower
inspired by some Mark's Basilica in
Venice affords the best views of the
city
[Music]
the viewing platform is 70 meters above
ground from up here you can see how the
close connection between the city and
the Baltic Sea developed over the
centuries the largest exhibits
documenting the city's maritime past are
found at the historical dock the
buzzards steamship is more than a
hundred years old and still seaworthy
now a MANET still takes to the open
water a perfect grade to compare today's
technology with that at the past
[Music]
the consular art gallery is also well
worth a visit the collection ranges from
20th century expressionist such as any
another to contemporary artists like
Yahara victor the venue also hosts
temporary exhibitions mainly of
Contemporary Art ladies and gentlemen
welcome on board the MS Hikind off we'll
be taking the two-hour mini cruise of
Kiel fjord
one of the biggest fjords in northern
Europe he'll fjord projecting from the
bay to the south is about 17 kilometers
long at the far end is lebu a popular
holiday resort the Baltic resort of La
birth is famous for its naval Memorial
which can be seen from afar it's 82
metres tall and at the top is a viewing
platform open to the public
from up here there's a great view of
keel field
[Music]
liebherr is also famous for its three
kilometer long stretch of white sandy
beach
[Music]
the romantically inclined will enjoy the
craggy Felix odd cliffs on the opposite
side of the fjord from lubber
[Music]
the - Pella cafe is at the fjords
narrowest point here ships have to into
their way forward with the utmost care
and you can watch them come and go
between keel and faraway places the
world over
[Music]